in recent years
open access has steadily gained momentum
most journals and publishers today have
open access channels and authors have
the choice to publish open access
however many authors particularly those
who are relatively new to academia
are still in a haze about open access
publishing
what is open access what is the
rationale behind publishing open access
what are the different venues for
publishing open access
such questions bother authors and they
are often skeptical about publishing
open access as there are several myths
about open access
open access is built upon the idea that
scientific research should be made
freely available to all so that others
can build upon it
and help escalate scientific progress
traditionally the academic publishing
industry has followed a
subscription-based model
this model requires readers to pay for
the content that they read
typically libraries purchase bulk
subscription to a journal
so that members or students can access
the journals
but as subscription charges for journals
started increasing
libraries found it increasingly
difficult to purchase expensive journals
this was particularly true for libraries
and institutions in developing countries
where funding was scarce
as a result researchers often could not
access studies that they wish
to and this started affecting the
progress of research
the need to remove this roadblock gave
rise to the open access model of
publishing in which readers have
unrestricted and immediate access to
research
after it has been published with the
permission to reuse it
what are the different venues for
publishing open access
broadly speaking there are two models
for open access publishing
golden green gold open access journals
give readers free access to
peer-reviewed articles
but the publication charges are borne by
the authors
today most big publishers offer open
access options
and some like clause are purely open
access
there are several major directories of
open access journals
most notably directory of open access
journals or doj
which can help researchers identify open
access journals in their field
under the gold open access model authors
have different kinds of journals to
choose from
full open access journals all articles
published in such journals are freely
available for readers on the journal
website
some of these journals are subsidized
and financed by an academic institution
a learned society or by the government
but others may require the payment of a
fee from the authors
known as article processing charges once
the paper is accepted for publication
hybrid journals most of the articles in
these journals are paywalled
with only some content open authors can
choose to provide
open access to their articles by paying
an extra fee this fee is generally known
as open access fee
delayed open access journals in this
model
articles become free for readers
sometime after initial publication
the time period for which the article is
paywalled is known as embargo period
for most journals the embargo period is
6 to 12 months
green open access under green open
access
authors publish in subscription-based
journals but at the same time deposit
their articles in an open access
repository
this is known as self-archiving thus
although the journal is behind a paywall
readers have free access to the article
through the repository
authors who cannot pay the fees for
publishing in open access journals often
take this route
however articles may not be peer
reviewed prior to posting in a
repository
another point to be kept in mind is that
not all subscription-based journals
allow authors to post their paper on a
repository
authors should therefore check the
website of their target journal to find
out whether self-archiving is allowed
and preferably take the journal's
permission before self-archiving
open access repositories can be
institutional or independent
subject specific such as bioarchive
nature precedings
and pubmed central or multidisciplinary
such as archive
there are three basic versions of an
article that can be self-archived in
repositories
pre-prints this refers to the author's
copy of the article before it has been
peer reviewed
post prints this also refers to the
author's copy
but after it has been peer reviewed with
the suggested revisions incorporated but
before the publisher has formatted it
for publication
and publisher's version this refers to
the final pdf of the article that is
formatted and appears in print or online
as mentioned at the outset authors are
often unsure about publishing open
access
this is largely due to some popular
misconceptions about open access in
their minds
let us try to dispel some of these myths
open access journals are not peer
reviewed
this is an absolutely wrong idea
a journal's peer review policy has
nothing to do with its access policy
most open access journals are peer
reviewed
open access journals have low impact
factors
this is once again a myth many open
access journals publish highly cited
articles
and receive high impact factors
publishing in open access journals is
expensive
authors often avoid publishing in open
access journals as they feel that they
will not be able to afford the high
apcs however the truth is that not all
open access journals charge apcs
and the ones that do generally have the
apcs clearly mentioned on their website
apcs vary across journals and are not
always high
additionally many universities or
funding bodies bear the apc's
also open access journals often waive
fees for researchers in developing
countries
and those researchers who are in
financial difficulty
for example many nature publishing group
journals have an apc
waiver policy open access publishing
does not offer copyright protection
or credit to authors in fact for many
open
access journals such as plaz or bmj
authors retain copyright after
publication
additionally most open access journals
use creative commons licenses under
which authors always receive
credit when their work is reused
in summary as an early career researcher
it is extremely important for you to
recognize the importance of publishing
open access
science can progress only when immediate
unrestricted access to research is
provided
we hope that in the coming years
researchers show more willingness to
publish open access
so that the scientific community policy
makers and the general public can
benefit from their research